what's up reject nation got ashley
and they're with me today i'm gonna say
this right away
follow her on instagram she doesn't ever
ask anything of me but for some reason i
feel like i always gotta tell you guys
to follow her
thank you and she never even i never
even say what should i promote
just like i'll just shout out her
instagram why not
that sounds good ash and i do love
horror movies my favorite
yes so i thought today with it being
thanksgiving season
let's watch 10 horror movie fates
worse than death one of my favorite
channels uh when it comes to list videos
is what culture and i just found out
they have a
one of their like sister channels or
whatever the hell you call those called
what culture horror they don't have as
many followers here but
i do want to check this video out to see
what they do here i'm excited this
sounds intense
yeah it'll just be a good list video
we'll see
horror movies have made it abundantly
clear over the years that death is not
the worst thing that can happen to a
human body
oh no take a peek behind the curtain of
a genre that prides itself on pant
sweating
impossible scenarios and you will find
far worse fate than simply having your
mortal light snuffed out by whatever
evil stalks the screams
from torture porn that is sadistically
drawn out to horrendous degrees to
paranormal trappings that can condemn
one to an eternity of suffering
to mentally pushing people until their
minds snap like a rubber band
there are plenty of ways horror movies
send a serious chill down your spine
without ever killing their characters
looking at some of the moments where
death would be a mercy then
these are the movies that made staying
alive the scariest horror of them all
i mean who knew that spiders could
thrive so healthily in human orifices
you learn something new every day i am
the grim reaper ash from what culture
and these are 10 horror movie fates
worse than death
10. becoming a sami's pet audition
audition sees ayama but widower decide
to try and find another wife by setting
up a fake tv audition to their potential
fiance swift
this sounds problematic of course and
the woman he chooses ends up punishing
his horndog behaviour
hassani the scamp eventually drugs and
slowly butches him with needles upon
discovering he hasn't been honest with
her throughout the process near the end
of the movie but that is not the fake
most terrifying here by a long shot
when ayama is drunk we learn about
asami's previous victim through what
appears to be a hallucination in asami's
home
kept in a sack and missing his tongue
some fingers and both of his feet
this tortured man is forced to beg
assami for food of which she guarded the
obliges by making him consume her own
freshly produced vomit
of course this might all be a dream but
when a sami cuts
a horrible connection is drawn between
the two that dictates exactly how the
man could end up should asami have her
way with him
being needled to death is nothing
compared to a life inside a sack with
only spew for sustenance
oh my
[Laughter]
own greatest fear setting up what's
intended as a simple discussion project
one student takes things too far with
those in his experiment by actually
putting the participants through the
horrors that they talk about
as the film devolves into anarchy it is
cheryl blooded by vegetarian due to her
father's past working at a meat
packaging plant before returning home to
abuse her
that gets the worst end of this deal
she's locked in a room with a steak and
left to see how long it will take for
her to consume it
tortured by the smell but unable to
survive otherwise cheryl
eventually succumbs to eating it after
days of decomposition
to earn her freedom from the room only
her freedom she does not get
instead she is rewarded with a human
body getting choked in with her
accompanied by the line let's see how
hungry you have to be to get through
that
oh oh no if being subjected to your
greatest beard
then suffering through cheryl's
absolutely would do the trick
thanks forcibly sectioned jesus
grave encounters it is one thing to get
sectioned into an asylum
what are these movies
in suitably scary detail but it is
entirely another to end up accidentally
committed to an institution full of evil
paranormal presences that want nothing
to do with your catch
intent on literally and figuratively
skewering your brain instead
and that is exactly what happens to the
crew of brave encounters
supposedly haunted psychiatric hospital
in glorious shanky cam
we watch as they are slowly abducted and
subjected to experimental treatments
from beyond the grave
with dr arthur friedkin's demonic ritual
practices in life allowing him to
continue
his unethical mind experiments in depth
the effects of this time-warping
space-altering hospital packed full of
unimaginable horrors
all of which want to commit you to their
world forever is just one huge note
really the only way out is having your
head scrambled by the evil doctor
himself but that's only if you haven't
already gone insane from the hell
hospital
this would be a cool maze yeah
horrors of another person invading your
body like a personal taxi shutting you
out of the driving seat to do as they
please whilst you are fully aware of
your own hijacking
it's a scenario that would quickly have
you looking to crash your body
car wherever this metaphor has gone at
high speeds into the nearest war
but it's not the first movie to dabble
with the terrifying potential
of body switching granted the skeleton
key doesn't trap you inside your own
head as another person takes over
like a racist parasite mainstay focusing
on full body and soul switcheroos
between two people
it's revealed that through the use of
hudu a couple have taken the bodies of
younger people to thrive for far beyond
their natural lifespans
jumping into them and sending their
victim soul into old
decrepit bodies that they then paralyzed
to protect their secret
instead of killing their chosen targets
the duo get their power through
convincing them that magic is real then
using it against them to confine them to
an old flesh prison for the reminder of
their drastically shortened lives
horrible i don't remember that movie at
all like
i've seen it so many times i've seen it
i'm like i don't remember any of this
purely on the grounds of being stuck in
a perpetual repeat of whatever awful
scenario has risen up around you forever
seems like the worst deal imaginable
1408 entrepreneurial
toys the endless golden flatteningly
real
and happy death they deconstructed the
trunk piece by piece right
but i'm going to talk a little bit about
in the tall grass instead
and why well because on top of the whole
endless time loop ravaging its
characters into non-existence
it also has a big old alien rock sitting
in the middle of it
one that conjures grass-based entities
and sensors that touch it insane
getting suck in a time loop is bad and
all but with strange
stephen king curated monsters that bring
you to life and condemn you to death
over and over again until you become one
with the strange grassy environment
thrown into the mix
[Music]
dude that sounds cool like a cool movie
not a cool experience
yeah fine that sounds like a really cool
movie
this movie is so great it's been a long
time
have shown us the perils of being made
into something no human should be
with yeah haunting enough for its own
shout out
yet the walrus suit still feels
is through the screen and is a truly
disturbing peek into what one trained
medical professional is so uncomfortable
yeah or not is a moot point but the
thought of being mutilated and
repurposed into a walrus of all things
is almost too bizarrely specific to
comprehend
wallace is so conditioned his new state
of being he remains as a walrus even
when he's free perhaps is the most
stressful part of all
four the idea of being morphed into some
sense of mass consciousness is another
that has been utilized across a few
movies
there's a few different conversations on
how the titular thing actually
assimilates its prey
and in the absence of any truly solid
facts surrounding the concept
i'm going to go right on ahead and say
it is pretty horrible joel said this is
a favorite movie
oh yeah don't die you have no joke
with a whole bunch of other creatures
from the universe over that have
suffered the same cruel fate
does that mean you never truly die and
are doomed to an eternity trapped inside
an alien creature using your face
as bait perhaps perhaps not depending on
the ambiguous truth of the movie
but the consideration of it alone is a
terrifying enough prospect to make death
a forget
option and even if you disagree about
how assimilation works then thinking
about a world overtaken where this alien
exists at all
is also pretty damn scary three
kidnapped by an otherworldly creature
obsention i don't know guys the first
one is still the creepiest
underrated low budget miracle from mike
flanagan centers around her missing
husband that inexplicably reappears
again just about when he's due to be
written off
as dead in absentia and whatever takes
him has the manners to come back for his
wife and eventually her sister too
it turns out some insecure creature is
stealing people away to a strange
paranormal realm where they're taken
through the physical wall of a tunnel
and kept in another dimension by
said creepy crawling it functions as a
perverse metaphor for a truck dwelling
in a tunnel
aka under a bridge and will only let its
victims go via very specific trade deals
what it does to its victims is never
revealed in fault but we know they
suffer an immeasurable amount
cannot escape and can see the world
going on around them whilst never being
spotted themselves which is a horrifying
concept
two spider eggs in their ears
torture movies are right for finding
these sorts of entries but inevitably
you can argue that they're all leading
up to the big event in the most
imaginative and painful process possible
and can a fate be really worse than
death if it's part of the process in the
first place
well that depends if your torturer is
intent on keeping their victim alive or
not
cough martyrs as the dares dominic is
throughout his prisoners capture
his whole sadistic deal is fueled by a
big dollop of vengeance just to make the
whole experience that much more personal
and you don't really get much more
personal than getting into someone's
ear canal darling decides that in order
to pay a debt of violence back to one of
the people he has captured
he's going to inject a syringe of liquid
into
[Music]
spider eggs spider eggs that then hatch
work their way through our sinuses
and burst out her mouth later in the
movie in a ghastly
sickening surprise oh no no no no no no
just
no one opening the lament configuration
hellraiser i'm surprised there's no
human centipede on this
one too reconsider just how strong
they're built on their best
struggling through the pains of a horror
movie for a lifetime even more so
but struggling through a pain dimension
connected to help set up to abuse your
everlasting spirit in an inescapable
plane of agony really does take place
you hear that pinhead
you get the top spot by a country mile
opening the lament configuration brings
about a horde of cenovites that will
judge you accordingly potentially taking
you along for the ride of their journey
through
time and space into all things hurt or
sending you to hell for eternal torture
the only possible good outcome is being
destroyed on the spot
but that is a luxury not many get to
experience
far more scary than death is the place
beyond it and if the hellraiser series
is anything to go by
you will want nothing to do with it in
the slightest avoid puzzle boxes kids
you never know what you're opening up
and if that's our list
what other horror movie fates are
absolutely worse than death
sharing your thoughts in the comments
centipede definitely should be on this
list
do they live in the human centipede yeah
don't forget to like share subscribe
oh i don't remember if they do i don't i
don't think that they would all have
live but i don't remember
that was stressful
what an uplifting video but that was
good
and not a strong one right the first one
that looked just
awful the first one was the one i mean i
know you got to hook people with your
list videos but to me that still
i i don't maybe because it felt the most
realistic of what
like the torture stuff and the vomit
yeah yeah
yeah that was so just to me that was the
most disturbing one i mean tusk is up
there though too
yeah to be turned into a walrus oh oh
yeah the makeup is just makes it all so
disturbing in that movie i forgot how
unnerving it was
like looking at it because i mean didn't
you just
yeah i just watched it again i mean i've
seen it a couple of times but that one
always freaks me out and then i've seen
uh the skeleton key a couple times too
which is that's like like a
fun ghost story i feel like new orleans
i guess if you take the context of the
skeleton key and then you break it down
you're like oh yeah i guess that's
pretty awful
i'm thinking about like the experience
of the ending and from what they just at
least
like i don't really don't remember that
movie but for what they described here
i'm like
yeah i guess that's bad that i remember
the torture stuff seems
a little bit more scary though i mean
you hear a video like this and that's
kind of where your mind is expecting it
to go
actually the human centipede i didn't
watch i i started it
i've seen it yeah it's pretty it's
pretty do they live at the end
i'm not sure you'll have to watch the
whole thing and see i don't want to
spoil it for you my experience was
that i heard what the human centipede
was and then i was like
i don't know if i should watch this and
then i put it on and then 20 minutes
before anything even happened in the
movie i was like i don't think i'm gonna
do this
the first one and then i watched a
little bit of the second one i heard
that one it's like
bonkers yeah yeah it's all it's a lot
have you seen the movie the lodge it
just came out
last year it's with the kid from it and
alicia silverstone but
that's like a purgatory-ish kind of
movie and that one
was that fate is worse than death you'll
have to watch that one
what are some horror movies i feel like
we could add on to this list
i mean like all the hostile movies
horror movie fates worse than death
oh i see because they toured i gotcha
cause they keep them alive you mean yeah
yeah because these people
live even though it's uh so
it's not just brutal death well some of
the saw i mean there's a couple people
in the saw movies that make it out after
doing
terrible things oh yeah they're
very disfigured for life yeah the one
girl had to like go into the guy and
like get the key
to get the thing out of her face but
they usually come out becoming
jigsaw i'm trying to think of other
movies that should be on there
i don't know watch i'm going to go home
all day include these text messages in
the video greg
oh i have another one silent hill
they're in like that purgatory hell like
place
yes and then they i assume at the end of
the movie i think they stay the woman
and the little girl stayed
there right so that's another one where
they are
alive okay so there you go there you go
i mean
they introduced a lot of movies here
that i was kind of surprised by
like i haven't seen most of these yeah
i'm not going to remember the ending of
most of these
but there were some that looked like so
appealing to me like the time loop one
that sounds like a really
crazy film and i love the concept of
that i
kind of don't want to watch some of
these because they just sound so
disturbing that first one i feel like i
kind of want to watch but not
i don't know about you know what's a
good one this doesn't qualify as a
horror movie but there's this uh
really popular korean movie that they
remade called
old boy that fate there's something
about it that feels like a horror-esque
but it's not a horror movie
that fate of the care have you seen that
no oh my god i bet i bet
you're uh let's see if you answer it
right yeah
i bet your fiance has seen that movie um
in that movie
that's intense that fate is one of the
worst that that
that shook me i like that that's one
where
i remember watching that movie by myself
like
why why did they go there oh my god i
was so
i was very much disturbed by that ending
and that's not a death ending that is a
uh really
disgusting twist psychological
yeah if you've seen old boy you know how
messed up that ending is
when i'm looking for an uplifting movie
i'll be sure to watch that have you seen
keanu reeves eli roth movie knock knock
no
okay then i won't spoil it but that
ending too is pretty awful
like i feel like that's a horror movie
and that could qualify for this list as
some
um you know you're yeah it's hard to
talk about things without spoiling them
the sloth victim
in the movie seven survives and that's a
pretty horrible
thing to still be alive for that's right
i forgot about that
it might not be the finale moment but no
but the person's still alive
are you talking about the character
that's in the hotel room that they yeah
okay
yes yes i agree i'm glad you do
good i was gonna say in krampus do you
have you seen oh yeah yeah
they're like stuck like in the snow
globe yeah but this is kind of like i
mean they're stuck in a christmas time
which at least is a little more positive
yeah exactly have you seen the mist no
you haven't seen the mist i feel like my
god all the movies i want to talk about
i can't spoil it i think the mist would
totally qualify for
i hate that ending to be honest it's one
of the most divisive endings
but oh i think i know what you're
talking about can i say
yeah sure is this like when he kills
like his family and then himself
he doesn't kill himself he kills his
yeah i mean you got half a right he
killed him
he kills his family and then like two
minutes later the army shows up and
he didn't need to kill him you need to
kill them yeah i
i hate the ending i i do i'm like you
mean to tell me he couldn't hear that
army
uh to live with that i think that is a
pretty horrible one and that is a horror
movie so i think that totally works
anyway yeah i thought this was a fun
list
i thought they really delivered here
they introduced some cool movies and
yeah
um yeah overall yeah these are pretty
horrible i'd say
it's pretty awful very scary happy
thanksgiving ladies and gentlemen
what movies do you think could qualify
for here follow ashley on social media
which is just one thing instagram yep
posting all the time subscribe click
that notification bell
subscribe to what culture horror last
but not least
fox fox is his name that's actually his
middle name this
new patron of ours i don't know his
first or last name but to have a middle
name like
fox i mean that must mean you're one
foxy ass dude all the way from durham
north carolina if i'm not mistaken is
that what nc stands for
i know geography no country no country
durham no country he's off the grid this
guy fox
i just gotta say since i don't know your
first and last name i'm gonna have to
give you a traditional shout out
f stands for funtabulous
o stands for ah
wait wait wait there's a great o word
and o stands for
oxymoronic that's great yeah and c
stands for is there's no c in your name
x
stands for f o c s x
stands for x-men
because you are cool enough to be the
leader of the x-men
thanks fox so much for being a part of
our channel for quite some time
means a lot to happy here yeah hopefully
you enjoy our patreon content
if not still stay pledged
bye
[Music]
you